rock and roll baby welcome to the game
design office of forge of Empires my
name is Pierre Koga and today I'm going
to show you our brand new content the
modern era which will take us back into
the time of the golden 1950s here we are
it's the time of rock and roll it's the
time of big Hollywood movies it's the
time of American diners and amazing cars
we really try to capture the spirit of
this era in all the buildings as you see
they're full of color they're full of
neon they're full of lights and they're
full of all kind of really cool new
stuff for instance what we have new is
new units we can go and have a look at
it here we are in the new part of the
continent map which kind of like takes
us to the Far Far East it's a little bit
Japanese themed let's go and attack this
sector of written Gozen by tacking with
our new modern era units among those we
have four paratroopers they have a brand
new skill the rapid deployment which
means they're gonna glide down on their
parachutes at the beginning of the
combat and also they are always going to
act first they have a really high
initiative so let's go let's see what
they're gonna do here they come they
hover down onto our Beach Maps they
really try to capture this the center
the atmosphere of the Far Far East of
the beach battles on the small islands
there and here they go away take out
Ringo zones are Tillery the rapid-fire
cannons also they have defense bones and
bushes here we go ba-ba-ba-ba-bom all
right another thing that's new in the
modern era is the good system the goods
they don't work as you guys are used to
we introduced a new concept to make the
game a little more challenging and
introduce something new to basically
force you guys and to think about new
strategies what how they how it's going
to work now I need to find a goods
producing building where did I put one
there
yes this one produces packaging and as
it works now in order to produce
packaging you need to put an old good
from colonial age into the building you
need to basically pay paper in this case
to be able to produce packaging and of
course you also can increase you can
boost the production by having a deposit
but it's not a new deposit that also
work with ours
using old deposits the ones from Bronze
Age as you can see here the concrete
plant for instance is boosted by rock
packaging Factory is boosted by trees so
if you have the tree deposit and you can
provide enough paper then you can go and
produce the packaging the new goods from
modern Europe of course we have a whole
variety of whole range of new
technologies to unlock all the new
buildings like the commercial aviation
where you can unlock the aircraft
factory and the modern chains where you
can start producing battle tanks not
only this we also for the first time we
give an Outlook of the stuff that is to
come of course modern era is not gonna
be the end of it there is more stuff
coming afterwards and we already give
you a teaser of the next year that's
going to be the past modern era which to
give you a big spoiler it's also not
going to be the last age of forge of
Empires there's still plenty to come
alright that's it for now I hope you're
gonna enjoy the new modern era I wish
you a lot of fun with it and see you
later alligator